underoos hey everyone I get to keep the
suit of course doesn't fit me just don't
do anything I would do and definitely
don't do anything I wouldn't do there's
that little gray area in there and
that's where you operate wait a minute
you want the real Avengers
but this does not mean you're an Avenger
in case you were wondering oh that's not
a hug I'm just grabbing the door for you
oh all right kid
good luck out there the world's changing
boys time we change too
mr. Peter forget the flying monster guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing like a kid but you are a kid this
is my chance to prove myself
don't mess with me
because I will kill you and everybody
you love
hey youtubers it's charlie happy early
Christmas new spider-man trailer with
different footage from the last one so
let's break it down there is another
round of the spider-man giveaway that's
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video make sure you click that
Bell to enable alerts so that you don't
miss anything
so this second trailer is way more
hardcore than that first trailer
focuses more on the action less on Peter
Parker is a high school character more
on the spider-man part of the movie like
you have a couple different things going
on here you have Peter Parker in high
school then you have him trying to
become an Avenger through the course of
the film learning to be a better
spider-man
so funniest line of this trailer hands
down is him dropping Peter back off in
his neighborhood after Civil War like
they kind of have a nice continuity with
the way they start the trailer at the
airport battle scene where he says yeah
you can keep the suit but if you think
this makes you an Avenger it does not
not hugging you just get in the door for
you good luck kid and it just pushes him
on his way so it gives you a lot more
context to how he fits into the Avengers
because I think technically he's an
Avenger but the whole reason that Tony
Stark keeps treating him like a kid
which is why he gets really upset later
in the trailer is because he wants Peter
to have the childhood that he never got
to have like his parents were killed so
he had to grow up really fast and we all
saw the montage in that first Iron Man
film like he had all these awards he was
this child prodigy but he had a problem
with women he had a problem with alcohol
he had a problem with just kind of
checking out in general like he was
completely checked out from reality
before he went into that cave in the
first Iron Man film so it seems like he
really wants Peter to have a normal
childhood like he doesn't want him to
get hurt it's not the he doesn't want
Peter to be an Avenger so the other big
thing about this footage is that it
teases the villain team up with the
shocker
in the Tinker in a couple other people
so like the Shocker is really the
biggest thing there's just a much better
look at his character so it seems like
the tinkerer is the one who's building
all the tech for like the shocker for
the vulture his flight suit so even
though Michael Keaton is going to be the
big bat of the film the vultures like
the big main villain you go from like a
really small team up to evolve
by the end of the film the world is
changing it's time we change with it so
that's also happening on the spider-man
side of things
spider-man is changing time for him to
evolve into a much more fully fledged
hero so you just have to remember that
this is the first film he's only a
sophomore in high school so he's about
16 years old so even though he complains
that Tony Stark treats him like a kid he
really is still a kid we can start
laying bets on how long it's gonna take
Tony Stark to officially acknowledge him
as an Avenger is it gonna take to the
third spider-man homecoming film is it
gonna happen at the end of this film the
other thing they have going on in the
background here is a lot of Miles
Morales stuff from the comics so his
best friend
Genki knows his identity so that's kind
of what they're doing with the Ned Leeds
character here and then people talk a
lot about how this is like a John Hughes
High School film that's what's going on
with all this lizallen stuff in the
Michelle stuff so it seems like he has
this super hard-on for Liz Allen who's a
really important character if you don't
read the comics she ends up getting
married to Harry Osborn in the future
they have a son together remember Harry
Osborn the son of Norman Osborn future
Green Goblin so no idea if they're ever
going to address that in the movie
probably not because at the end of this
trilogy they'll all be about 18 years
old so Peter really likes lizallen but
the thing about John Hughes films is
it's usually about not seeing the thing
that's right in front of you because
you're too caught up with your own
[ __ ] so look to the side and who is
this person here who Peter just barely
recognizes so that is the person that
he's probably going to end up with at
the end of the film because they did all
that promotional stuff with zendaya like
how many interviews have you seen Tom
Holland do with this lizallen character
all of his interviews have been with
zendaya so very clearly she's going to
be a huge character in the film but the
way they sell it in this trailer is that
Peters all about Liz Allen so
something's going to happen during the
film and he's gonna see the thing that's
been in front of him this whole time so
speaking of things being in front of him
the whole time at the front of his class
up on the board here you see a picture
of Bruce Banner now because all these
pictures look like great people in the
history of the world in the history of
science the reason he's on there
probably
has something to do with his research
into gamma like there's always lots of
gamma jokes that they stick into things
like the joke at the beginning of the
first Avengers film where dr. Selvig
like we don't know what's going on with
a tesseract it's giving off all this
gamma energy it should be okay and then
Nick Fury [ __ ] his eyebrow and it's
like oh I've seen gamma do some really
terrible stuff before and everybody
knows that he's talking about the Hulk
so you have Peter Parker stuck in high
school with the Iron Man voice over look
kid I know high school sucks I know you
want to be an Avenger you want to be a
hero but you're not ready yet so
throughout the course of the film he's
gonna be stuck in this really mundane
life dreaming about being an Avenger so
along comes the vulture all these are
the big villains provides him the
opportunity to try and prove himself
this is my chance to prove myself that
was one of the other most important
lines in the trailer and it looks like
it happens at the Washington Monument
where it seems like is like the first
big vulture attack so if there's any
question this is the Tinker and we don't
know exactly who Donald Glover is
playing but current best guess is that
he's the Prowler and I know a lot of you
are wondering it's totally possible that
the Shocker is the person that's robbing
this atm just because of the gear that
he's using so that could come back later
when they team up with the vulture
everybody evolving the world's changing
time we changed with it so like the
Shocker gets like super awesome gear by
the end of the film just like the other
villains just like spider-man getting
cool gear by the end of the film - but
let me know which of these trailers you
like more the first one or this one here
I think most people actually like the
international version of the trailer
better just because it hypes the action
a little bit more but what's gonna
happen is is I will do a spider-man Q&A
this weekend so leave all your questions
about the movie about anything you want
me to include in that later today I'll
post my legends of tomorrow finale video
and then I have like a ghostwriter
agents of shield videos that I'll also
try and get out this weekend but lots
more comic book stuff happening this
weekend it's gonna be really fun
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch that other
spider-man trailer to compare the
footage and you can click here to
rewatch the guardians of the galaxy
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you